dan what would you say separates the
films that make it into the Holly shorts
Film Festival against those that don't
get in I think going back to story and
completion of a story I think the
biggest thing is this kind of two parts
is one films that don't stay true to
what their story is you know yeah so I
answer this part of question and we'll
go back is there's not a side of it the
obvious stuff as well but the films are
don't complete you know the Galata said
they still go out and the filmmakers
said to make a certain story or make a
certain film intellisense door and they
go on it turns out to be this is trauma
then it turns into some type of uh yeah
you know over-the-top Ranji comedy and
then like that like did Tara throw three
four John pictures into one 15-minute
short and the films are all over the
place and then it becomes confusing for
us during probably be confusing for an
audience and their story gets lost the
film becomes unenjoyable
there's problems of the act like you
just kind of sense of some of the
snowballs that way those kind of films
where people were trying to tell their
showcase their abilities in many
different ways instead of just staying
true to the one story they need to tell
no you are dealing with short form short
content it's a short film it's not a
feature film feature films can have that
that kind of that type of texture and go
longer and you can kind of go into
different periods of story and you know
in backstory whatnot but when it becomes
a short and not make a feature and you
don't have that same luxury and so going
back to that some filmmakers you see you
know get with cramming everything and
they also you know and I'm gonna just
throw this out there I just we were not
a fan of the lengthy opening credits on
a short film very annoyed about that I
just gotta be I want to say the other
thing on the program is I've talked it
like it's just something that you know
you're not you know it's not a feature
film you know it's not a feature
production so you want to give everyone
these needs that great that's a Chris
that's not the point
but create should be at the end those
credits are deserved but to open up with
that kind of that kind of cred sequence
without telling your story it's wasting
time you have a minute to thirty minutes
tell your story tell your story you know
and in too many these films come in and
just yeah I guess I'm following a model
maybe they see feature films thing okay
I don't make a film like this and that's
now
you're making I mean some of the best
shorts when we can't like just go right
in the story and go right into it and
I'm just how much creates all sometimes
if at all now that I'm not saying I'll
have credits at the end erotic credits
at all
reading credits and opening but just
these like full-on you know associate
producer credit so when I in the
beginning of the film this is not it's
not the place for that I think a lot of
programmers probably in harsher than we
are about it I'm not gonna like say no
to a film so that's it it's done but
it's some of this it's distracting to me
and again if you're not getting to the
story very big thing this way we're
sitting around watching films all day or
even if you just watching a certain
amount in a day you're still you know
we're going to be on work kind of
critique mode with me you're going to be
kind of little more critical you know
it's good to see stuff again sometimes
and kind of back off that and just kind
of you know enjoy the film and you know
and not be as harsh I suppose but
watching stuff for a period of time if
you are watching all day against other
films and something like that is going
to be a negative deterrent it doesn't
help doesn't help so that's one thing I
said you know filmmaker should avoid
fruit when it comes of shorts and in
different programs I think they feel
probably the same as we do on that but
that part of that does this the story
again the issue of telling multiple
stories and once in one film you know
trying to showcase different sides of
the talent like styles you know the
maybe they're trying to emulate certain
styles for filmmakers I've grown up
watching so you have like again not like
a focus of the film you know and that's
that's a problem it's a problem it's a
probably see a lot and we have films
that are very you know they're the
stories told and very nice flow to wait
if it's the most simple of stories but
it's told in beautiful ways and it's
executed that's what we can appreciate
and that's what we can look at so clear
why can't we program there's no reason
yeah give me any reason to say no it's
kind of one way we look like alright
this film had the elements needed to
have you tell that story to the best
Academy I had no reason to say no to the
film so that's kind of we're like okay
then we're going to find out home for
this program because it just it just the
film works and there's no reason to say
no to them
you